hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel as you can see I look slightly
less like a discount version of Sam
bankman freed today the reasoning for
that being that I am about to go out uh
this is actually my last time going out
in New York city so I'm actually in a
bit of a rush to get the night started
so let's make this video quick today
we'll be talking about actual serial
execution so let's get it started okay I
have whipped out the iPad and I've
whipped out my dick let's get started so
actual serial execution what is it well
basically in the past few videos what
we've done is we've talked a lot about
weak forms of isolation the reason being
that actually achieving transactions
that don't step on each other's toes and
cause race conditions is not only hard
to do it's also expensive to do it makes
the performance of the database much
slower and so when actually trying to
achieve full serializability or
isolation we need to make sure to take
care to actually keep performance as
good as possible or else our databases
are going to be pretty useless at scale
so one attempt at doing this is actually
come around a little bit more recently
and it's known as actual serial X
execution the reason I've put volt DB in
parentheses is if you're curious to see
an actual example of this in the wild
you should look up volt DB it's
basically doing exactly what I'm going
to describe in this video so what is it
that actual serial execution actually
means well for starters basically CPUs
are faster than they used to be and so
now as opposed to having to necessarily
rely on multi-threading one thing that
you can actually do in order to make
sure the transactions are just running
in order and not running at the same
time is literally running them in order
and not running them at the same time so
all we're doing is running every single
thing possible on just one core and so
there are some limits to this right
because obviously if we were doing
everything in a multi-threaded way that
allows us to get a lot of performance
gains on multi-core processors however
you know putting everything on one core
is going to require some extra work on
our end to make sure that things are
fast enough so there are a couple things
that are going to limit the performance
of your system if you're running
everything on One Core so the first
thing is going to be using a disk right
I've drawn this picture of a hard drive
many times over and the fundamental
issue with disks is that they are slow
we've got this metallic seeking disc and
as a result it's just going to be a lot
slower than using something like an SSD
or perhaps even better literally keeping
all of your data in memory so we've got
a couple of things here the first thing
is that we should be running pretty much
our actual serial execution on a
database that keeps everything in memory
and it's got some pros and some cons
that come with that the first thing is
that it's going to be faster right we
can use our hash index or if we want
support for range queries we can use a
self-balancing binary search tree based
index like a red black tree and AV L
tree something like that but it comes
with the cons of a having far less space
right memory is more expensive so most
computers don't have as much of it and B
and more importantly the data is not as
durable I didn't even write that there
but you know it's something that I
realized you can use a right ahead log
but then now you're writing to disk
again and that slows things down the
other important thing we're going to
touch upon a little bit more is that the
network is slow right so what is it that
you're actually conveying to a database
well of course there's some data that
has to be written but if you're just
running you know a certain complicated
query actually sending that query to the
database itself can be slow so let's
imagine that you know we're YouTube and
we have this basically SQL script right
subscribe to channel.sql and we're
sending that over the network from our
server
to the database
and what if that you know script is
effectively long enough that maybe it's
two kilobytes in size compared to the
actual data which might just be like
literally putting uh one name in the
subscriber column of a channel the
actual script itself can be a lot of
data and network bandwidth is obviously
going to be a lot slower than just
running instructions off of a CPU so
it's very important to minimize the
amount of data that we're sending over
the network so how can we do that well
basically in order to do this we would
use something known as stored procedures
so if you've heard of stored procedures
it's probably actually in a negative
light the reason being that generally
speaking you don't need to use these
stored procedures are basically when you
know before you even start running your
database running your application you
send a bunch of SQL functions or the
functions could really be in any
language to your database saying here
are the types of commands that I'm going
to tell you to do and when I want to
invoke these commands all I'm going to
do is you know send over a parameter
right so you know we're going to
basically call the function we're going
to give it it's our arguments so for
example if we want to add inventory to a
certain product maybe we have the SQL
script for that already pre-loaded onto
the database and what we would do is
send over something like the product ID
and the quantity right and so that way
that's a lot less data that we're
sending over the network than the entire
SQL script to add the inventory with the
product ID and quantity hard coded in
right the product ID is probably just
literally a number so 32 bits and the
quantity is another number so 32 bits
compared to you know however many
characters that script might actually be
okay so what are the advantages of the
stored procedure well of course like I
mentioned it's less data to send over
the network and that's hugely important
when every single thing that we're
sending over the network every single
write that we have to do is
bottlenecking all of our other rights
because they're only occurring on one
single thread
on the other hand stored procedures
themselves are not great to use the
reason being that just for a developer
they're kind of a pain in the ass it's
annoying to kind of keep these in line
with your other code because you know
it's held on the database it's not as
easy to check into your version control
system it's not as easy to deploy these
in a good way you know especially if you
have multiple instances of a database if
you have replicas or anything like that
it's not so easy to you know kind of
send all of these stored procedures to
all of them but in conclusion guys
basically the general gist of this is we
know the underlying Assumption of how
we're achieving isolation is we have to
do it on one chord so what's every
single possible optimization that we can
do in order to make those reads and
writes on that single core as fast as
possible the slower the reads and the
rights the more delay that every other
operation becomes because they're
effectively all just enqueued on this
single core anyways guys I know it's a
short video but I got to get out of here
and get drunk so have a great night and
I will hopefully see you soon